e torna ai solita storia io sono gli 30
e oggi il nuovo episodio della serie le
scelte più difficili al mondo mi sono
piaciuti un sacco questi video e anche a
me piace un sacco fallì perché ci piace
vedere cosa scegliete voi nei commenti
ci piace vedere cosa ci diamo noi prima
mi piace vedere cosa scegliamo noi e
cosa significa quindi come funziona
facilissimo non essere sì domande e voi
due
e voi dovrete rispondere nei commenti
anche noi risponderemo vediamo fare
queste risposte sono quale alle mie
opere di vitale
vediamo un po alcune domande sono molto
molto difficili siete pronti prende tipo
corno tè caldo che è litio subito allora
preferiresti fissare uno schermo bianco
per una settimana oppure mangiare solo
che il top per un mese basta è facile e
fissare lo schermo bianco per una
settimana intanto nel frattempo posso
mangiare quello che voglio non è così
difficile però non puoi fare nient'altro
de visto correre la schermo pià
e vabbè ho capito dovrò farmi mangiare
ora non è che avrà una settimana omaggio
vogliono due giorni nostri che mangi
magiche top no no sappiamo per vita la
cosa importante mangiare quindi però
anch'io scegliere chi sarà lo strumento
perché non so se mangiamo che per un
mese in effetti rimane in vita
non lo so voi cosa scegliereste magari
siete grandi fan del che sapesse
commentate numero due
ogni dio
credibile scherzando manderesti tuo
figlio o tua madre ma lo zio poi in
questo caso noi non abbiamo nessuna
figlia quindi è facile se di voi cosa
scegliereste magari se c'è qualche mamma
ma è una scelta impossibile numero 3
preferiresti essere sordo o re stupido
non so perché sennò la bocca sembra
quasi essere sordo essere muto quindi o
sono stupito dipende stupido quanto
sordo probabilmente perché stupido
oppure forse dovrei dire stupito perché
stupido già usate da un autogrill fan
sardo sv risorse e poi mi sa che non
puoi neanche parlare perché no perché
non senti la sua volta indice di
comunque io penso che scegliere che
stupido perché
non ci riuscirei a non sentire a non
parlare non sentire sarebbe bruttissimo
ma anche se le stupidi e monitorare la
quale dopo dc nostre sei stupido perché
magari è vero ti sport insomma voi cosa
scegliereste
scrivete nei commenti numero 4
preferiresti essere una ragazza però con
i baffi per sempre quindi che non li
puoi togliere oppure essere un ragazzo
avere sempre il rossetto è solo il
ragazzo aveva sempre rossetto sessi e
poi te lo togli tanto piacevole aree
sopra il matto uno come totti rimane
sempre fitto quindi sì fisso su
politiche o no quale forse scritto forse
non lo puoi mai togliere ti va bene
capitale col rossetto che sto benissimo
e messo tutto allora essere una ragazza
col baffo molto hot io no preferirei
essere un ragazzo col rossetto magari
faccio vita che il mio colore nazionale
delle labbra
a parte che non c'è niente di male che
un ragazzo si mette al rossetto quindi è
un ragazzo col rossetto quindi
decisamente il ragazzo col rossetto
ma cosa vuol dire un sensi di marcia una
ragazza ha i baffi dipende da quanto
sono forti quindi scrivete la vostra
risposta nei commenti vediamo quale se
niente 15 preferiresti miller in un
mondo dove nessuno soffre o vivere in un
mondo dove tu comandi 30 30
allora questa domanda un po così perché
scegliere mi viene subito da scegliere
un mondo dove nessuno soffre soprattutto
vabbè per i bambini per le persone per
gli animali gli animali che soffrono
però penso magari un mondo dove tu
comandi puoi fare in modo che nessuno
soffra lo stesso però dipende da quanto
sei bravo come andare perchè un pò
difficile gestire tutto il mondo
quindi io sceglierei un mondo dove
nessuno soffre più bello che sarebbero
sarebbe bellissimo anche tu quindi voi
cosa scegliete è perché mi raccomando
ogni risposta dovete scrivere il perché
così vediamo qual è il vostro
ragionamento 16 che tutti ti mentano
quindi che tutti dicano menzogne
oppure che tu dica menzogna a tutti
oddio crespo veramente difficile perché
è brutto non vorresti mentire a tutti
però lo stesso tempo stuzzichi mentono
non sai non ti fidi di nessuno non sai
mai quale la verità è davvero difficile
quale se diventa 80 intanto a tutti one
ha sì senza scrupoli proprio perché è
perché è più facile e più perché sono
tutti quanti diventano terre non sai più
cosa fare una pd nessuno vestito sia la
risposta è facile anche se mi dispiace
perché poi sei tu quello che mette a
tutti e sei falso e lui ti crede per
nessuno e ma non lo sanno
però sì cioè tutti che ti mettono penso
che rimane veramente solo e triste però
potreste rimanere isolato perché tutti
dicono che tu metti sempre quindi
nessuno tv sebbene tocca a scegliere
aspetta però se tu scegli che tutti
quanti ti mettono e tu lo sai già già
non credi a tutti dice allora sento in
montagna no io soldato in collina
offriamo la terza verità che avevano in
collina dove sta veramente finale più
difficile però il cambio dico che tutti
mi mettono così modelli di vento brava a
capire menzogna scoprirla bene allora
voi che senza scegliete scrivete nei
commenti
con teo che domande brutte essere
l'unica persona al mondo solo solissimo
oppure avere amici ma che ti bulli zano
ogni giorno
oddio è terribile
no assolutamente non essere da solo
mondo si no non riuscirebbe a
sopravvivere troppo triste però aspetta
l'unica persona non dice animali 15
potresti circondare di tantissime rivali
tantissimi candidati coprente l'unico
essere umano però tutto il resto
animali si sono quindi già destro mamma
mio uomo intendo però è circondati da
animali tressanti avevo pensato
sennò avresti solo amici che ti bulliano
ogni giorno secondo me è meglio essere
storiche avere amici che ti polizzano
ogni giorno vorrei cosa scegliete e ci
circondiamo di animali di tutti i mali
campbell e allora io vado dove sotto le
stelle da solo 8 di età che vedono cane
un gatto non riuscirò a scegliere per
salvare questo gatto che sta accadendo o
salvare questo cane che sta accadendo no
allora io dico il gatto perché il cane
non mi sembra che stacca la fisica ne
sta guardando il gatto è affacciata una
tenuta che succede come quello di
controllare e carlo stalli che guarda
regia di catherine per il volo libero
quindi se li amo il calcio sperando che
il cane non cadrà con mano il canelli
che osserva stata stato i pedoni pronta
ad abbagliare quando
con qualcuno che non gli piaceva ma voi
cosa scegliete salvare il gatto o
salvare il cane è perché ora 9
preferirsi dormire in un letto con come
si chiamano con dei chiodi o dormire in
un letto
8 di aver fatto di pietra sembrano così
comodi tutte e due di quello fatto di
vlc è quello con ignoti potrebbe essere
un attimo che attrae ovviamente non
provato la casa però l'abbiamo visto in
un museo maxxi tutti quanto accadrà così
pistola
magari non lo so volete per
sperimentarlo mettete chiusi no non lo
fate
se tutti tra il dritto in un letto di
chiodi non ti certo punto la pietra morì
di freddo durerà questo e un francese
d'inverno 0 sull asta è più fresco e poi
se spacchi a schiena
però sì meglio la pietra direi voi cosa
scegliereste però 9
preferireste avere una tigre come
animale domestico o avere un leone come
rimane domestico
allora innanzitutto non li vorrei come
rimando messo perché a parte che la
tigre e il rischio di estinzione strada
tanto purtroppo proprio per queste
persone qua che sia le cacciano per
pellicce per venderle o di tenerle sì
cioè verame terribile e tristezza vabbè
comunque nessuno di loro vorrei che
rimanessero liberi però se proprio
bisogna scegliere ovvia dire che power
avrei paura che vengono a mangiarmi la
notte nominata volta però indiano di
mangia che facciamo finta che che sono
tanto buoni come i gatti finisce di
fatto sono dei gatti più grande però
anche i gatti a volte team organo per
toccare provare che ti mordono attaccano
un braccio films che sceglierei la tigre
di più la tigre anche un po meno gigante
dovesse scegliere
bellissimo cosa software che non le
nostre due bellissimi e livelli voi cosa
scegliereste tigre o leone mano 10
preferiresti vivere senza prodotti e le
apparecchi elettronici o vivere senza
amici molto difficile questo perché
istintivamente direi senza parecchi
elettronici
magari si tornerebbe più alla realtà e
si uscirebbe più con gli amici
non lo so si farebbero più cos'è
all'aperto però se vivessi senza parchi
eletto nel sindh non potrei fare i video
su youtube che è la mia più grande
passione
oddio 8 bevesse gli non lo so è davvero
difficile non riuscirei a vivere senza
youtube ma sarebbe tristissimo non avere
amici sì non penso che io sceglierei non
aver apparecchi elettronici perché
comunque se ce l'hanno fatto prima di
noi senza parecchi elettronici così
sofisticati che ce lo possiamo fare
anche noi a ritornare indietro lo
approverete da vizi serve un pò 3
fidanzato non include amici
[Musica]
voi cosa scegliereste scrivete nei
commenti per studi in continuazione o
avere orecchie e morbi ma a differenza
delle orecchie enormi quindi è a posto
hai già scelto io preferirei orecchie
enormi sperando di poterle coprire quei
capelli di magico estrema con cappello a
mettere dentro il cappello picchio le
orecchie grandi granzotto e voi cosa
scegliete scrivete nei commenti
dovrà dove si preferisce famoso su
youtube
oppure essere famoso su facebook che
cosa facebook facebook.com arabia no
comunque se usate peso seguitemi su
questo la mia pagina ea leader tory
comunque decisamente su youtube youtube
è la piattaforma migliore detto di no
nome youtube è la migliore di tutte
ormai youtube
voi cosa scegliereste scrivete nei
commenti o 13 preferiresti mangiare solo
cibo congelato o mangiare solo zuppa per
il resto della tua vita ma cibo
congelato nel senso lo puoi scongelare e
mangiare lo devi mangiare conti a lato
secondo terzo
penso che c'è che includa solo cibo
congelato cala di mangiare si fanno
sempre alla zuppa non legate di mangiare
caldo dovrebbe quindi da un lato su
questa preferire trance la tutela la
scuola macellate e pronti rompi denti
anomica congelato che la roma non lo so
secondo voi è congelato nel senso che lo
mangi freddo o da provato che poi ci
penso io a preoccupare forse stavo
congelato che lo puoi cucinare allora
decisamente congelato stai messo e
congelate che lo devi mangiare
ghiacciato preferisco l'azzurro ma chi
sa che vorrei che preferite santori si
preferisce mangiare questo burger o
darlo a lui un povero bambino non sto
morendo di fame
a prescindere il burger non lo mangiava
rito
in italia li facciamo finta che un
burger vegetariano beh decisamente da
rocchi sta morendo di fame va mi sembra
ovvia ma perché la fanno proprio questa
domanda se magari dargli anche qualcosa
di migliore da mangiare che è così
infatti molto di più e qualcosa di più
nutriente decisamente lo darei lotteremo
al bambino che sta morendo di fame non
mi sembra ovvio c'è vedere se qualcuno
risponde no perché l'altra volta
nell'altro video c'erano persone che
hanno risposto che butterebbero il
gattino invece dell'iphone ten perché
preferiscono tenere il telefono che è la
vita del gattino e se io sono ancora
scioccato da quelle risposte
vabbè ognuno ha le proprie cioè il tè
priorità di questa era la fine del nuovo
episodio di cosa propri redditi e senza
più difficile al mondo
clicca qua per vedere le altre gli altri
episodi così vai a rispondere anche le
altre domande e vediamo se le sue
risposte sono stime e quelle degli altri
o no rimasto scioccato da questa scelta
come se si giocasse di più a te questo
definitivamente senso il difficile era
quella bugia
sì è vero se piccole rho più difficile
secondo voi qual era la più difficile e
ora vi lasciamo qualcosa che non scocchi
cliccare per vedere l'altro episodio
delle scelte più difficili pur potesse
cliccare un altro quadratino che vi
piace di più è buona visione